UTTAM TRIPATHI:
Hello, and welcome
to the new, exciting show of
GDL that we're recording out
of the India studio.
With me, I have today
is Anirudh Dewani,
who is the DPE developer
program engineer on the Android
developer relations team.
He has worked with Indian
developers for many years,
so I think he's
an expert to talk
about what Indian developers
have been building
and what are some of
the advice that he has.
So welcome, Anirudh,
to our show today.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Thanks, Uttam.
It's great to be back in India
and to be joining you guys.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: It's a
pleasure to have you.
So before we get started,
Anirudh, talk a little bit more
about the kind of
Indian developers
you have worked with,
the kind of partners,
and what do you see is a common
trend emerging out of India.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So
when I was in India,
and I was for the
last three years--
I just recently moved
to New York this year.
So when I was in
India, we worked
with a lot of top media
companies, news companies,
and a lot of the big,
big, big partners.
And we also interacted
a lot with the community
and developers who are
independent and building
some amazing apps with
some innovative stuff,
a lot of startups.
So we worked with
the entire spectrum
of developers and content
generators here in India.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Great.
So let me start with this.
What do you think is one common
mistake that you see developers
from this part of the
world, from our region,
make when they build an
app and put it out there.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So what I noticed was that
the apps that were coming out
of India were really
feature heavy.
I mean they would try to do
a lot of things, wherein they
could instead concentrate
on a smaller feature set
and maybe do it in a better
way, providing fuller,
complete experience
to the user, focusing
on more important stuff like
UX and navigation and all
those things.
So instead of
making cluttered UIs
and packing in a lot
of functionality,
remember it's a mobile device.
The real estate is limited,
the use is limited,
and you have to take
care of touch targets
and provide appropriate spacing.
So instead of making it
feature heavy and cluttered,
just focus on a lesser number of
things and make them beautiful.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Great.
A question that we
get-- a common request
we get from developers-- how can
we get featured on Play Store,
what does it take
to get featured?
So what would you say
are the top three or five
things that the teams look
when they are deciding
on getting an app
featured on Play Store?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: In general,
the experience for the user
should be amazing.
So when you start with that
mentality, you would do well.
So that includes building the
right UX, following the patents
and guidelines that are
published by the Android team.
And there are plenty
of those to make
your app consistent
with the other apps
and the system UI itself.
We regularly update
our guidelines across
whenever there are
new version releases
and there are new
things coming up.
So I would say navigation,
interaction design, UX,
and support for all
sorts of devices.
Support for tablets
is important.
Making no assumptions
on user behavior.
There are some developers
who release their app
with just a portrait or
a landscape orientation,
thinking this is how a
user would use my app.
But there are users who
have different habits.
So taking care of these
things are important,
and they really go a long
way in bringing good reviews
to your apps.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Great.
How important would you say
is focusing on tablet apps,
or making sure that you have
a tablet version of your app?
How important would
you say is that?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So
really, there are
a lot of large screen
devices that are coming.
And it's important for users
to experience your apps
on these devices.
I myself am a heavy
user of a tablet,
and I look forward to access
my favorite apps on the tablet.
And there are a lot of
tablets in the market that
are there now.
So it's really important now
to focus on tablets as well.
During your development
process, if you
get that thought
in early, that you
have to build a
tablet-friendly UI,
it's actually much easier
to achieve the goal.
There are many developers
who start out with,
OK, I'm going to do
a phone UI, and maybe
after six months or one-year
period, I will do a tablet UI.
That actually complicates
the development process.
So if you have those
goals set in your mind
that my app should
run on all devices,
there are features of
it in the framework,
like fragments,
that can help you,
can actually go a long way in
making it simpler and easier
to develop applications.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Great.
I think that's great
feedback for the developers.
So you talked about these
best practices and guidelines
that are documented.
Where can developers
go and find them?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So in
our developer site,
which is developer.android.com,
we have a section dedicated
to app quality, where we
enlist the core app quality
guidelines, which cover the
basic things that an app should
have.
That includes permissions and
policies and interaction design
and stuff like that.
There are tablet-specific
guidelines available.
And then there's
a section on how
to improve your app quality.
So if you launch an app, and you
start getting some user reviews
and ratings, which say,
OK, this is crashing here,
or this is really
inaccessible, I
could not find this
feature in the app.
How do you engage with the user,
with groups and communities,
and other things in
this one, user reviews,
with reply to review features?
And so there is a whole
section dedicated to that.
So we will have these published.
And the other thing that we
have is there's a lot of content
that comes in forms of videos
on YouTube and posted on G+
by our engineers, the
members of my team.
And there are videos that are
dedicated to helping you design
your apps really well and
performance tips and stuff
like that.
So yeah, there's a lot
of content available.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Great.
Yeah, so just get
all the guidelines,
the best practices on
developer.android.com,
follow the team on Google+.
Also, I think you guys are
very active on Stack Overflow,
so these can be some
of the avenues-- some
of our developers can get
in touch with the team
and get the best practices.
So finally, before we move to
the second part of our show,
we will have you talk about
the latest things that
have come out with
the Android KitKat.
What would be one
final advice, if you
are asked to give one advice
to developers in our region?
How can they be
really successful?
What would be that?
ANIRUDH DEWANI:
Focus on the user.
And there are some
important considerations
when you're in an emerging
market like India,
in terms of data
connectivity and stuff.
So focus on those things,
make sure you do not
load heavy assets on lower end
devices, which are available
and plenty in India.
So taking care of that
stuff, making the user
experience really
wonderful, is--
and by following all the
guidelines that I mentioned
about-- is what you
should start with.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Great, I
think that's a great feedback.
And great advice for all the
developers in the region.
So the second part
of the show, I
want you to talk about-- we
had the recent Android update,
the KitKat that came out,
and a lot of developers
have already been using it
and playing around with it.
But if you can talk
about some of the key
highlights that
the team rolled out
as part of the
latest release, that
would be really useful
for our developers.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Right.
So we've always had this
theme with Jelly Bean,
about their UI as what we said.
So with KitKat, the
focus was really
on creating an operating system
and a framework for apps, which
would chart a really
low memory footprint
and making it run on
lower end devices.
I think the number published,
we said, is 512 MB of RAM,
is what KitKat should run on.
And that's especially
relevant for, again,
in an emerging
market like India,
right, so this was a
really important project.
There was a lot of
engineers working
towards making
the footprint low.
And so we've enabled some
APIs also for developers.
There's an API where
you can find out
if your app is running
on a low RAM device,
and then you can
adjust accordingly,
adapt your application
to lower specs.
So this was a big effort.
There are some tools that
came out of it, like procstats
for helping you
analyze process memory.
Apart from that,
there were a bunch
of features that came out.
There's the host card emulation
for payments and gateways
and a lot of programs,
which can help
you make NFC-based
secure payments.
We rolled out a completely
new print framework,
which can allow you to print
your content over Wi-Fi
or cloud services like
Google Cloud Print.
It can also help
printer manufacturers
to write their own
pluggable modules, which
can enable you to interact
with special printers
that they may come out with.
There was a lot of improvement
in the media platform,
starting with support for DASH
and captioning and adaptive
playback.
Apart from that, we rolled
out the new storage access
framework, which would help
apps to retrieve documents
from their preferred document
provider, maybe Box or Google
Drive or whatever it is.
It's a common UI,
a consistent UI.
And then there were
a lot of features,
other features of two new
profiles added to Bluetooth,
and a new hardware batch
and framework for sensors,
which reduces your power
consumption on the device,
support for captioning in
the accessibility section.
Yeah, a lot of
features came out,
and these are all detailed
on our developer site again.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Great.
Yeah, it sounds like a
lot of exciting stuff
that the team came out with.
So with that, this is the
wrap for today's show.
I'm sure you guys would follow
some of the advice and best
practices that Anirudh had
to talk to you guys about.
Also, the latest things
that were rolled out
as part of the Android
KitKat release.
I'm sure that you guys
are already working on it.
We can't wait to hear more
about what you guys are working,
so do get in touch with us on
Google+ and some of the other
channels that Anirudh
mentioned here.
And we would like to learn
what you guys are working on,
and our goal is
to make developers
successful in the region.
So with that, it's a
wrap for today's show.
Thanks once again for joining
in, and I'll see you guys soon.